[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal de tv et 78 tour d'horizon de
l'actualité locale
tout de suite les titres de ce mercredi
5 décembre les 14e rencontres et lucau
des skis se dérouler hier à guyancourt
rendez vous consacré cette année à
l'offre de formation et d'emploi pour
les jeunes du cp au bts sur le
territoire rencontre dans un lieu qui
n'est pas anodin le campus des services
de l'automobile et de la mobilité
le personnel du centre hospitalier de
plaisir en colère hier une centaine de
personnes a manifesté devant
l'établissement et dans les rues de la
ville cible du mécontentement les
projets d'économie de la direction avec
notamment des suppressions de postes
trois représentants de l'intersyndicale
à l'origine du mouvement seront en
plateau et j moins 3 avant ce choc
versailles reçoit samedi le mythique rc
lens pour le 8e tour de la coupe de
france de football eux supportent
habituellement les rugbymen les membres
du collectif ultra versailles et seront
pour l'occasion derrière les
footballeurs nous en perdons à la fin de
ce journal
comment rendre le territoire attractif
pour les jeunes le codis qui conseille
de développement de saint quentin en
yvelines y réfléchit depuis plusieurs
mois hier soir l'instance rencontrer les
élus au campus des services de
l'automobile et de la mobilité de
guyancourt les précisions avec ce sujet
de nicolas landry et de mélanie poker
pour cette rencontre annuelle place aux
jeunes la cible les 18 21 ans diplômée
du ceap et au bts
le code est ce qu'ils proposaient pour
cette soirée des ateliers de réflexion
et de partage avec les élus du
territoire
on a constaté avec ses travaux que il y
avait une
un trou démographique entre 18 et 30 ans
à saint quentin en yvelines d'or aucune
ville eau qu aucun territoire aucune
agglomération ne peut vivre sans
jeunesse pour pour la vie de la ville
pour la vie des entreprises pour les
enfants se servir des établissements de
formation et entreprises pour améliorer
des problématiques déjà connu l'habitat
la mobilité et la vie sociale
quand on les a écoutés lors du
diagnostic et bien ils ont été très
clairs et ils nous ont dit vous savez le
territoire oui effectivement on vient y
tuer ni étudié puisqu'à une université
on vient aussi travailler parce qu'à des
entreprises mais on n'a pas envie d'y
rester parce que le soir
c dr parce qu'il n'y a pas de lieu de
rencontre de lieux festifs
un peu comme à paris développer le
territoire autour de l'économie
l'industrie numérique de demain ou
encore les services à la personne le
codis qui s'appuie sur une enquête
proposés aux jeunes âgés de 18 à 30 ans
nous c'est notre sondage ifop plus notre
laboratoire d'intelligence de créativité
voilà qui qui qui nous donne quelquefois
même des contres des contrats dits par
rapport aux nôtres au contraire donc
c'est ce qui fait que entre les élus de
l'agglo et les élus du codesria ya une
synergie et ça augmente la la qualité
des décisions le conseil de
développement nous permet permet de nous
accompagner dans ce cadre là en ayant à
la fois des habitants la fois des
acteurs associatifs à la fois des
acteurs économiques du territoire des
acteurs de la formation l'éducation du
territoire sur saint quentin en yvelines
plus de 65000 personnes au moins de 20
ans le personnel de l'hôpital de plaisir
en grève hier une centaine de personnes
a manifesté devant les locaux de
l'établissement action également auprès
des automobilistes et barrage filtrant
sur la départementale 11 une
mobilisation contre les projets
d'économie de la direction à l'appel
d'une intersyndicale qui regroupe trois
syndicats du centre hospitalier de
plaisir en plateau trois représentantes
valérie louis délégué sud muriel démarre
secrétaire fo et comme il ne pas peut
déléguer sud merci d'être avec nous sur
ce plateau alors avant de parler de ces
sujets de mécontentement dans le tract
que vous avez distribué que vous avez
également fourni à la presse
vous partez d'un constat qu'aujourd'hui
l'hôpital est malade tout à fait parce
qu'on est de 30 depuis quatre ans nous
avons perdu 187 postes nous en perdons
encore aujourd'hui et nous allons encore
en perdre puisque certains sont encore
programmées avec fermeture du standard
réunification des deux standards
fermeture de la blanchisserie et
fermetures sur des lui sur certains
services avec aussi des suppressions
postes à la clé sur des services
regroupement de services techniques
administratifs
donc aujourd'hui on assiste à une
précarisation de l'emploi
on a plus de 350 cdd dans
l'établissement faut savoir qu'il ya
quelques années à plus d'un an et demi
on nous avait retiré au niveau de la gms
je parle donc il ya un des deux hôpitaux
nous avions trop précises une chose et
non pas les moindres c'est l'hôpital de
plaisir ce sont deux textures qui ont
fusionné au 1er janvier le centre
hospitalier jean-martin-charcot l
hôpital gérontologique et médico sociale
et donc au niveau de l hôpital
gérontologique et médico social nous
avons nous avions trois jours de congés
présentéisme
qui était donné tout ce qu'ils avaient
pas d'absence ou très peu dans un
trimestre ou moins qu'au trimestre ils
ont été supprimés donc en 2017 avec la
promesse de stage et reese et 20 cdd de
2017 à 2020 ça c'était pour nous c'était
promis acté à la direction commune qui a
eu donc auparavant et en fait on n'a eu
qu'une seule année des stages irisation
donc on a perdu ses trois jours il ya eu
une économie de réaliser au niveau de
l'établissement et pas de stages
irisation à la clé nous sommes toujours
au même point avec des cdd qui durent
parfois plus de 5 ans donc des
suppressions de postes y ont eu lieu qui
vont encore avoir lieu il ya une autre
motif de conti ces contestations pardon
c'est le passage à 7h30 de deux journées
de travail contre 8 heures avant c'est
ça qu'est ce que ça quelles conséquences
ça entraîne ce qui se passe c'est que
les économistes sont faits sur tous les
domaines depuis déjà un bout de temps
vient d'expliquer madame le papa est une
manière de faire des économies c'est de
modifier la charte du temps de travail
qui permet en répartissant le personnel
sur des durées différentes de travail de
supprimer des postes
on avait deux chartes du temps de
travail une sur la partie psychiatriques
etc sarko qui était très favorable au
personnel et une sur la partie hms donc
géronto et médico social que très
défavorable aux agents et bien
évidemment de par la fusion c'est sur la
la charte la plus défavorable qu'on va
être tous alignés et pour l'hôpital donc
ex charcot où on est quand même plus de
six ans le fait de nous aligner à 7h30
alors qu'on était à 8 heures va nous
permettre de supprimer 13 jours de repos
sur l'intro spitalier salaire les gens
qui sont une hospitalisation et cinq
jours de repos par an sur tout le reste
des structures soignants technique
administratif et en fait c'est
récupération de deux jours qui vont nous
faire travailler en plus va leur
permettre de supprimer une dizaine de
postes sur l'ensemble de l'hôpital
or on n'est pas que des heurts ont aussi
les personnes et le fait d'avoir des
gens au moins va forcément avoir un
impact déjà sur nos vies privées sur le
laissant sont les trajets sur les frais
de garde aussi sur les façons
les gens parce que la façon de supprimer
le temps de travail c'est aussi de
supprimer l'heure et demie de relève
qu'on avait le midi et qui permettait de
faire des accompagnements de faire des
réunions de faire tout le travail
atteinte aux verts le connaissent de
conséquences quelles sont les
revendications du coup aujourd'hui comme
muriel démarre pardon je me tourne vers
vous mais les revendications alors ce
que vous avez déjà rencontré votre
direction à ce sujet en tout cas auprès
de la presse elle n'a pas souhaité
réagir pour le moment cette direction de
l'hôpital de calais les avons rencontrés
six fois sans véritables négociations
puisque s'était imposé plus ou moins ils
avaient déjà leur idée en fait on s'est
aperçu que ça qu on avait un petit peu
mener en bateau dans le sens où on nous
a demandés on essayait de nous faire
faire des propositions alors qu'en fait
ils avaient l'aigle idées toutes faites
de d'aller à 14 heures ni té puisse
faire 15 heures tt 14 points puis si la
journée solidarité
donc en fait les étés voulait aligner
absolument pas par le bas donc on a
essayé négocier en que ce soit sur la
psychiatrie ou sur les autres nuits où
toi tu es plus plus à même d'expliquer
ce qui s'est passé par rapport à la nuit
tout simplement par rapport au personnel
de nuit depuis sept huit ans ils ont des
nuits supplémentaires de payer 11 mois
sur 12
s'était octroyé quand même depuis 7-8
ans et ils vont en perdre une certaine
partie donc ça fait entre 250 et 500
euros par mois en moins pour certaines
personnes et de deux week-ends
travailler ils passeront en plus en
trois week-ends travailler ce qui fait
une grosse perte financière et l'hôpital
de plusieurs sens en revanche la
direction locale le plaisir je le
précise qui souhaite ne pas réagir et
elle réagira juste après son comité
technique d'établissement qui aura lieu
vendredi prochain alors juste une
dernière question est ce qu'on arrive à
la fin de cet entretien la mobilisation
perdure depuis le 16 octobre
vous êtes déterminé vous allez jusqu'au
bout avoir lâché le mouvement et ne
serait-ce que de savoir ce qui va être
présenté
ce qui va le présenter vendredi
puisqu'on n'a pas le nouveau projet la
salle à changer de lieu
on a l'impression qu'on essaie de nous
perdre
et de nous appliquer au 1er janvier 2019
la charte qu'ils auront décidé en dehors
de toute démocratie au niveau des
instances représentatives et recel
dernière question comment vous avez
échangé avec les automobilistes hier
comment ils ont perçu la situation et un
départ à 6 francs notamment les gens
sont très attachés à leur hôpital a
plaisir à leurs deux hôpitaux qui est
devenu un
il ya eu quelques lequel trois personnes
en tout sur les milliers de gens qui
nous ont klaxonné qui nous qui nous ont
soutenu qu'on fait des tours de rond
point supplémentaire pour nous soutenir
on a eu un très bon accueil dans les
gares aussi dans la population de
plaisir où il ya quand même pas mal de
personnes âgées où il manque quand même
pas mal de place à l'heure actuelle au
niveau des ehpad des maisons de retraite
et on voit à chaque fois que nous nous
avons fermé des lits
nous en avons quand même fermé beaucoup
dernièrement 119 en 2016
on s'aperçoit qu'il ya des groupes
privés qui arrive qui ouvre qui prennent
au lit en fait d pad mais qui sont pas
du tout le même temps des faits qui peut
payer aujourd'hui 4000 euros par mois
corinne le papillon elle démarre et
valérie louis merci à d'être passé sur
ce plateau représentant de
l'intersyndicale pour ce mouvement au
centre hospitalier de plaisir 25 lycéens
et lycéennes des yvelines et du val
d'oise ont signé hier à versailles leur
engagement pour devenir à cadets de la
gendarmerie un dispositif reconduit pour
la deuxième fois en ile de france il
s'agit d'un partenariat entre la
gendarmerie l'éducation nationale et la
fédération nationale des réservistes et
réservistes opérationnels et citoyens de
la gendarmerie nationale tout au long de
l'année scolaire c'est gendarmes vont
encadrer des lycéens recrutés sur des
critères scolaires et sociaux le
principe c'est de les aider à préparer
les concours de la fonction publique y
accueillir les accueillant lors de
stages pour développer leur esprit de
cohésion ainsi que leur esprit citoyen
et républicain propos recueillis par
aurélie rose
ces jeunes qui qui qui veulent intégrer
ce corps c'est qu'ils ont déjà ses
valeurs ou en tout cas ils ont besoin
mais j'étais ils ont si ils ont aussi
besoin de ça parce que c'est vrai que la
gendarmerie c'est quand même c'est la
rigueur ccc la droiture cesser toute
chose et si on veut venir là c'est qu'on
partage ses valeurs
depuis tout petit
être dans la poule i gendarmerie ça a
été ma passion étant donné qu'on papa
est un policier
donc j'ai toujours voulu être un futur
gendarmes
donc c'est grâce à lui que je me suis
lancé dedans elle ne pas oublier ses
anciens c'est important à la proche des
fêtes de fin d'année la ville de trappes
propose à ses seniors à des colis ou
dîner de noël les distributions se
dérouler cette semaine encore manon un
radeau a assisté à l'une d'entre elles
des seniors heureux le sourire aux
élèves touchés grâce à la distribution
de colis noël elle était organisée à la
salle des quatre saisons en mairie de
trappes la ville de trappes est plutôt
plus connu pour sa en extrême jeunesse
mais nous avons aussi quand même 3200
personnes âgées enfin ce qu'on appelle
les seniors maintenant et donc sur ses
3200 personnes
nous voulons les honorer et les
remercier d'être les seniors avaient le
choix entre deux sortes de colis de noël
les rouges constitué de provisions salée
et les colis noir exclusivement sucre et
une petite attention très importante
pour les anciens ça fait toujours
plaisir de recevoir le produit c'est
tout quand on est seul
les enfants sont un peu dispersé donc
j'aime tout ce la trappe
au moins ça fait chaud au coeur
le colis c'est une joie cette heure
attachement aux événements qui se
passent dans la ville c'est une très
bonne idée de la ville de trappes de
donner un petit quelque chose à sécu les
personnes qui n'ont pas bénéficié des
colis sont conviés un banquet organisé
par la ville de trappes 300 personnes
sont invitées et le passage du père noël
est attendu dans 20 jours pour faire
patienter les plus petits la ferme de
gally à saint-cyr-l'ecole la mise en
place sans un programme d'animations et
d'ateliers intitulé noël et merveilles
un monde féerique que nous font
découvrir aux rayons et patrick jacques
de dixmude aux mails eu sa part dans son
pot on rajoute de la terre tout autour
planté soi-même son mini sapins de noël
ou confectionner sa bougies en cire
naturelle
pour cette nouvelle édition de noël et
merveilles la ferme de gally a revêtu
ses couleurs de fête et propose aux
enfants tous les samedis et dimanches
après midi de nombreux ateliers pour 11
euros chaque enfant pourra également
s'initier à la boulangerie ou encore
manier l'argile des animations liées aux
fêtes de fin d'année tout en côtoyant
les animaux de la crèche
un concept qui plaît aussi bien aux
enfants qu'est leur paraît pouvoir
montrer aux enfants la nature de pouvoir
passer du temps au grand air et de
profiter de l'extérieur et puis
l'ambiance est toujours super chouette
la déco tout ça voilà ça fait des supers
souvenirs en famille ce qui est bien
c'est que c'est complètement d'hiver
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut pas faire
en ville quand on est en habitat près de
paris et on n'a pas l'espace de faire
tout ça un petit peu de voir les vrais
animaux plutôt que ce qu on y monte dans
les livres donc là on lui montre en vrai
c'est la première année que la ferme de
gally inaugure cette formule de noël et
merveilles une atmosphère féerique et
chaleureuse voulu parler qui se partage
entre les parents les enfants autour des
ateliers etc tous ces petits souvenirs
qui ramène le sapin et c'est qu'ils vont
voir pousser dans leur jardin ou sur
leur terrasse une magie de noël à vivre
jusqu'au 16 décembre à la ferme de gally
ascensions des cols et des biens qu'est
ce que tu as préféré qu'est ce que tu as
aimé
[Musique]
en attendant elle est faite aussi les
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
organise leur marché de noël c'était le
cas montigny le bretonneux dimanche
dernier 27e édition de cet événement à
la ferme du mas n'est plus de dix mille
visiteurs sont venus rencontrer les
quelques 135 exposants présents une
bonne occasion de trouver des idées
cadeaux et gourmandes ont vu à des
prochains repas copieux propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude le retour des habitants et il
est très positif parce qu'ils sont
habitués à l'heure à leur commerce à i
command
ce sont des fidèles pas forcément des
élus montrent un on a beaucoup de gens
des alentours également et au niveau
artisanat comme on à 30% de nouveautés
donc les gens sont satisfaits de voir de
nouvelles choses et d'acheter pour leurs
cadeaux de noël les marchés de noël qui
vont se poursuivre à saint quentin en
yvelines dès ce week end la féerie s'en
tinrent à samedi de coignières sur la
place de la mairie et de plaisir c'est
au parc et du château le samedi et
dimanche le week-end d'après à
guyancourt et à la verrière samedi 15
décembre ces marchés de noël seront
placées sous le signe de la solidarité
samedi 15 décembre également rendez vous
du côté de magny les hameaux sur le
parvis de l'hôtel de ville
villepreux également organise son marché
le samedi 15 décembre c'est son marché
noël donc sur la place du marché sa
porte bien son nom deux jours de
festivités du côté de
voisins-le-bretonneux les 15 et 16
décembre au centre sportif les pyramides
à maurepas sur la place et jacques
riboud et à elancourt devant la mairie
trois jours de marché les 14 15 et 16
décembre
enfin trappe attendra le samedi 22
décembre pour proposer aux habitants sa
féerie de noël
le fc versailles face à un monument du
football le club yvelinois reçoit ce
samedi le rc lens pour le compte du 8e
tour de la coupe de france de football
coup d'envoi à 13h30 au stade mob aurons
dans les tribunes plusieurs milliers de
supporters attendus parmi lesquels les
membres du ku bonsoir lucien gasparin
alors vous êtes vous êtes le
vice-président du cube c'est le
collectif ultra versaillais et vous
appelez à une large mobilisation ce
samedi pour l'équipe du fc à versailles
déjà cette affiche face à lens qui est
troisième de ligue 2 en 8e tour de la
coupe de france on ne pouvait pas vous
pouvez pas rêver mieux pardon pour
versailles
oui j'aurais pas dit mieux on appelle à
une mobilisation
a sion général pour un club mythique de
ligue 2 qui en plus se marchent très
bien
est ce qu'on veut c'est faire connaître
notre mouvement grâce à cet événement
historique et qui peut déboucher
peut-être sur un très beau parcours pour
le fc versailles donc c'est pour ça
qu'on se mobilise qu'on est présent sur
les réseaux sociaux et qu'on donnera de
la voix pour soutenir les joueurs du fcv
samedi alors votre mouvement justement
le cube est appelé en général à
supporter plutôt le rcv non pas le fcv
le rcv c'est le rugby club de versailles
alors qu'elle est ce collectif
exactement pas l'histoire a débuté pour
le rugby et elle continuera pour le
rugby après ce match
d'ailleurs on sera en fera le
déplacement dimanche pour l'équipe de
rugby à mourens il est donc ça
gros week-end pour le collectif travers
ça y est c'est une histoire qui a
commencé en 2010 est donc c'est une
bande de copains des joueurs de l'équipe
réserve ont décidé de soutenir avec une
première dans sa quête de remontée en
fédérale 3 et donc on est tous les
week-ends présent pour les copains parce
que c'est
c'est un mouvement très proche des
joueurs et voilà petit à petit au
mouvement prend ont été peu nombreux
puis maintenant un vrai collectif se
crée et ce sera l'occasion de faire nos
preuves ce samedi face au rc lens et
pourquoi se mobilisent et justement
cette fois ci pour les footballeurs
c'est un moment historique pour le sport
à versailles mais même si le week-end
pour le cube c1
c'est un grand moment de soutenir le rcv
l'alleud pour le fc léo c'est lens qui
vient ça va être diffusée à télé et on
se mesure face à une grosse équipe de
ligue 2 mais aussi à face à un gros
collectif de supporters qui sont les
supporters de lens qui qui sont très
connus en ligue 2 mais qui sont aussi
connus dans l'europe entière pour leur
ferveur et c'est un très beau défi pour
nous
comment a été accueilli l'initiative par
le club de versailles le club de foot le
club de foot bas était assez réceptifs
on a reçu beaucoup de messages de gens
qui sont d'habitude avec le fcv et qui
souhaitent venir avec nous dans le
cortège pourra monter jusqu'à la tribune
pour soutenir ce que ça va être
je pense à des plus grands moments dans
le square versaillais si toutefois y
avait victoire et
donc on va donner de la voix et orgue
râle on regardera le score que à la fin
du match et pendant 84 a dit me dois
chanter au stade et mon bord on pousse
pour soutenir les joueurs du fc vous lui
disiez vous le disiez juste avant en
tant que supporters le rc lens ça vous
évoque beaucoup de choses oui balayé les
corons les tribunes pleines les champs
tout ça c'est ce que ça nous évoque et
c'est ce qui nous motive à relever ce
défi de supporters en fait c'est
l'occasion c'est un forcément un public
mythique du championnat de france le
public du stade félix-bollaert un public
unique et qui à ce chant célèbre des
cours ont écouté
[Applaudissements]
ces supporters du rc lens parmi les plus
réputés en france vous savez s'il vont
venir nombreux à versailles je sais
qu'ils vont descendre y apprend grand
donc je sais pas mais je sais que ce
sera le cuivre qui se rendront pour
soutenir le fc et quel accueil vous avez
vous allez leur réserver est ce qu'il y
aura un duel entre les deux clubs de
supporters ça va être une grande fête
pour l'interdît et logistique ça on
laisse le club du fc sion occupé mais
pour la partie supporters on s'en
occupera il y aura beaucoup de surprises
pour pour soutenir les joueurs oui oui
comment ça se prépare beaucoup de
surprises vous n'avez pas les révéler
forcément mais on peut s'attendre à des
tifos deschamps spéciaux pour ceux des
champs des tifos des cortèges et surtout
de la voix comme on le fait tous les
dimanches à porchefontaine pour les
joueurs du rugby mais là on a essayé de
passer au stade supérieur
et donc là ça se prépare on est dans les
délais derniers jours la csn louis saha
proches c'est samedi donc vendredi ce
sera mise au vert et puis samedi jour de
match sur le côté sportif trois
divisions séparent les deux équipes le
rc lens est l'actuel troisième de ligue
2 versailles et 9e en nationale 3 il ya
des équipements avec deux dynamiques
différentes en championnat la coupe de
france on le sait elle peut donner
toutefois des surprises mais c'est ce
qui nous motive c'est ce qui me motive à
aller les supporter c'est de la magie de
la coupe de france c'est on aimerait
bien parcours là que vit en fait allé
jusqu'en finale et baptisé qui peut plus
fort que nous et donc c'est pour ça
qu'on sera présent dans les tribunes
samedi on appelle à une mobilisation
générale
une déception tout de même c'est le
forfait du gardien de versailles charles
itandje qu'un ancien professionnel et ex
joueur du rc lens c'est dommage ça
aurait pu être mais de le voir jouer
contre son ancien club où on invite
parmi nous est d'accord mais les
supporters pour soutenir un petit
pronostic
un pronostic est bas
mon coeur souhaitent la victoire de
versailles pour que le sport
versaillaise se porte au mieux est ce
qu'il reste des places pour ce match
puisque les ventes sont déjà ouvertes
elles se poursuivent je sais que les
cuisses sont rués sur les places mais
oui le stade nombre ont une bonne
capacité d'accueil donc je suppose
qu'ils restent des places fillon va
croiser les doigts pour ce versailles
lance merci à lucien gasparin est
d'abord été avec novices et président du
collectif ultra versaillais versailles
lancée ce samedi à 13h30 au stade mont
boron biétry encore ouvertes jusqu'à
vendredi sur place sinon vous pourrez
également suivre la rencontre à la télé
sur la chaîne eurosport 2 mercredi jour
de sortie au cinéma jour de notre petit
tour hebdomadaire également dans les
salles obscures saint quentinois cette
semaine nous nous rendons à l'espace
philippe noiret aux clayes-sous-bois
c'est au micro de patrick jacques de
dixmude
[Musique]
retrouvez cette semaine à l'espace et
philippe noiret le film astérix et le
secret de la potion magique quand vous
propose en sortie nationale
alexandre astier donc signe ce film avec
une histoire originale
on retrouve donc les ingrédients de base
ces personnages prennent vie y est
notamment donc d'irréductibles gaulois
jeu césar etc et il va ajouter comme
ingrédient donc des personnages
notamment un personnage de données
méchant voilà très bien très bien
dessiné et là il a reçu en salle et les
leçons culinaire de d'alfred hitchcock
puisque meilleur est le méchant
améliorer le film et il va aussi ajouté
un autre ingrédient alors ça je vous
dévoilerai pas mes un même personnage
plus moderne qui va trancher un petit
peu dans l'univers moustachu de
de la bd voilà donc c'est à retrouver
cette semaine donc la potion magique
d'alexandre astier avec l'humour qu'on
lui connaît
cette semaine à l'espace philippe noiret
[Musique]
pour refermer ce journal retour sur cet
événement les amis du passé d'elancourt
organisé leur deuxième salon du livre le
week-end dernier des auteurs présents
sur tout le site et des conférences avec
un fil rouge historique reportage de
marie lehn iapichino les images dites
upp stand bergès après un succès l'année
dernière les amis du passé d'elancourt
récidive avec leur salon du livre à la
commanderie
cette année plus de 70 auteurs ont
répondu présent
la dame qui viennent m'acheter un livre
eh bien elle m'a vue sur télématin sur
l'a2 il ya trois semaines on voit que
c'est pratique d'être très proche du
public de ne pas faire seulement les
grands salons nationaux
disons que c'est mieux parce que la
taille est plus humaine on va dire que
les grands salons parisiens
c'est justement cet aspect de salon
local qui séduit auteurs comme visiteurs
moi j'aime beaucoup les salons autres
que ceux de paris sud paris c'est le
salon des éditeurs c'est pas le salon
des auteurs ça fait vivre voilà les
petites communes et les auteurs
indépendants les petits éditeurs et je
pense que la force vive du livre al se
passe ici une édition avec une
thématique historique choisi par les
amis du passé d'elancourt avec le
soutien de la ville et de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
on a profité de la du centenaire de la
fin de
la guerre de 14-18 pour étendre pigeon
voyageur jusqu au numérique évolution
des communications à travers l'histoire
mais ce salon se veut large et tout
public des romans des thrillers des
livres d'histoire de la poésie et de la
littérature jeunesse
on a augmenté le
le nombre d'auteurs jeunesse comme on a
trois semaines de noël pour les cadeaux
de noël et on a une dont une vingtaine
d'auteurs jeunesse un salon automnal
désormais inscrit dans les agendas des
lecteurs saint quentinois
comme pour l'édition précédente 2000
personnes sont venues échanger avec les
auteurs et repartir avec une dédicace
c'est la fin du set 8 journal édition a
retrouvé en replay sur notre application
mobile et notre site internet dans un
instant un nouveau numéro du 7-8 débat
sur la thématique et du télétravail
belle soirée avec tv 78
[Musique]